so it's seven o'clock you're watching
Sky News breakfast coming to you live
from Buckingham Palace
the country and the Commonwealth are
waking up to the first day with a newly
crowned king and queen
tens of thousands joined in the historic
events with pageantry and some protests
red arrows and rainfall
[Music]
Prince William posted a behind the
scenes video of his family writing what
a day thank you to everyone who made it
happen
and the lady with the sword Penny Morton
says she practiced for the coronation by
doing press-ups
and today the celebrations continue as
thousands or Street parties are planned
across the country
[Music]
but we'll hear from some of the people
hoping to party again like it's 1953.
plus we'll have a full Roundup of how
the papers are reporting the king's big
day
foreign
hello a Very Good Morning Britain is
waking up with a newly crowned king and
queen if the enduring images of the
coronation will be the splendid and
sometimes strange ceremony at
Westminster Abbey today is about what's
happening in communities across the
country hundreds of thousands of people
are expected to take part in Street
parties and what's been called a
nationwide big lunch and then tonight
there'll be a star-studded concert at
Windsor Castle including Lionel Richie
and Katy Perry well more on all of that
in a moment but first our home editor
Jason Farrell reflects on an historic
day
emerging from an ancient ceremony into a
modern world the crowned King Charles
III
and waiting for him in the 260 year old
gold State coach is Queen the title held
by his mother now his wife's
even with eight horses the four-ton
gilded Carriage can only be pulled at
walking pace
but Majesty is in part about being
magical and it seems there are millions
captivated by it
fairy tale carriages or the Splendor of
a 4 000 strong military parade
or family Saga the embarrassing uncle on
Parade
and Rebel's son now best-selling author
pitching up without his wife
and the coach carrying the dutiful
future heirs to the throne
it is soap opera mixed with the Opera of
Royal pageantry
an elected official couldn't do what
they do it's just so perfect they're all
just it's fairy tale it brings everybody
together there's Unity that's a sort of
it's the proudness of being British it's
it's that's what the Monarch is all
about
thousands have come here just to be in
Touching distance of History because of
course the coronation is something we've
not experienced in decades but for that
same reason it's left others asking
whether we've moved on from what it
represents
there was a Zone set aside for
protesters but some mixed with the
royalists on the Mao
one here arrested for bringing a
megaphone that police said may have
spooked the horses I feel strongly that
we should have we should elect any head
of state or any anybody with any
ceremonial responsibility and we've got
a wonderful country full of talented
people who who aren't who don't inherit
privilege and wealth
[Applause]
but most came here to Revel in a legacy
they don't want to own earlier watching
on a giant screen in St James's Park the
moment the King was crowned
but invited to pledge allegiance I swear
no one had the words to hand
except this bit
oh yes I pledge my
answer to the incredible moment uh one
that I'm glad I got out of bed for in
the morning to come and witness what a
historic day absolutely fantastic you
know Long Live King Charles III makes
you proud to be British I love what he
does for the country I love the royal
family first off and I think we need
continuity and we need somebody who can
represent everything about the
traditions of this country
foreign
there is continuity but unfamiliarity
too in seeing a man so many years a
prince now head of state head of the
Church of England and head of the Armed
Forces
[Music]
[Applause]
saluted by those who serve under him in
Buckingham Palace Gardens
his authority rests on regimented
formality and the passion of the public
whether they connect with him
certainly there was a rush on the Mao
for the best view of the finale
[Applause]
but in some ways the endurance of the
last Monarch makes this rebirth harder
her absence still felt as the king
appeared on this balcony for the first
time ever without his mother
instead a blended family grandchildren
from both sides taking Center Stage
notably missing one brother and one son
these are the faces of the future the
working Roy
and those who are next in line to take
on this role
unlike Royal occasions we're used to
such as weddings and jubilees this is
not just a celebration but a day to
affirm the Majesty of one man
the late Queen described the Imperial
Crown resting on Charles's head as
unwieldy
[Applause]
now he will know what it's like to wear
it Jason Farrell Sky News
[Applause]
well I have with me two people who
enjoyed yesterday enormously the author
and historian Sir Anthony Selden and the
Royal commentator vikantes hinchenbrook
better known to many as Julie Montague
so welcome back to both of you and
Anthony Sultan King Charles waking up
this morning how will he be feeling do
you think how will he be looking back on
yesterday
I would imagine that he would think what
a great day that was
that thank goodness nothing went wrong
but also an awful lot went right and the
the reception has been very positive he
was it was a very difficult challenge
because he had to modernize the
coronation 70 years ago Britain was
still a great Imperial power a very
different country it was still very
white still very mono culture and there
was a much greater sense of deference
and respect for the royal family and
from aristocracy uh it was so different
and if he modernized it too far he could
have lost his core base so it was a much
more modern inclusive much fairer
representation of Britain today for some
people didn't go far enough for some too
far but I think he would have felt got
it just about right or went off
beautifully he didn't drop anything
nobody dropped anything and there were
no bad incidents you know that's a huge
worry for the security services always
with an event like this I mean like the
funeral when if people had bad
intentions that have had little time to
plan for it everyone knew that it was
happening today so I mean a fantastic
effort from the security side the Hidden
Side the people we never see but an
amazing effort by the British State too
to put Britain on at its most historic
and best and the music Sublime yeah at
12 newly composed pieces as well yeah
any service all of it very very
beautiful and Julie do you agree that
the balance that was struck was about
ride of ancient and modern in terms of
appealing to people making them feel
that it was relevant but also
extraordinary and and what will they
have made it as it's beamed around the
world
I I think at first when you know word
came out that peers would not be invited
um apart from a ballot system so they
wouldn't be wearing their robes or their
coronets I think of course there was
some I think disappointment but he did
get it right you know I look at the
family that I married into and it was
Edward Montague the first Earl of
Sandwich who brought back Charles II
from exile to then be crowned in 1661
and there has been an Earl of Sandwich
uh in my husband's family attending
coronations since 1661 until yesterday
my father-in-law wasn't invited we
weren't invited and that is the right
thing to do and but instead two of our
farmers were invited and we know that uh
King Charles started in 2010 the
prince's Countryside fund and he has a
you know a huge hand in helping local
farmers smaller Farmers with advice and
with France and that was represented
yesterday so it was wonderful to see
that it again it was much more inclusive
I think that was the right tone to take
so more inclusive Julie but but what
about the the spectacle of the regalia
of the of those ancient Traditions what
do people make of it abroad what do
people make it in your in your home
country of America well Nobody Does it
Better ceremony or pageantry or rituals
better than the Brits and so we still
got all that you know we saw the Saint
Edwards Crown we saw the Imperial State
Crown and we we saw the ore of the
scepter the robes so it was still
spectacular you know there were bits
that were missing but then there were
other bits that were added that really
emphasized how different of Coronation
this is and and that was wonderful to
see and as you mentioned the music was
spectacular the and it went out you know
went off without a hitch and that I
think was the most important uh and
wonderful to see I answer you refer to
the fact that on a security front things
were went smoothly as you say a huge
relief there were protests there will
also been a lot of people that weren't
interested you know not just actively
protesting but just not interested at
all how much of that represents a
challenge for King Charles to to keep
the monarchy relevant in his Reign well
absolutely it's a huge Challenge and the
work really does begin for him now how
is he going to show all young people all
those who who just couldn't care less
about it and there were large large
numbers who were doing other things I
walked back yesterday and was surprised
by how busy Victoria Station was in
London how many people during the
service who really didn't seem to have
any interest in it at all how can the
royal family show in an age of democracy
I mean 1953 everyone kind of got the
monarchy and and they the war of second
world war just been over and very
prominent role from George the sixth
during that as George a fifth in the
first world war now you can't take that
for granted and in a democracy what do
young people think they think okay we've
got a prime minister we get that we got
Parliament MPS what is the monarch uh
what does the head of state do and I
think they have to show that the uh the
the sense of the continuity of the royal
family and the issues that Charles
believes in like the environment which
he's championed almost better than
anybody that you know some there's an
ongoing role for the royal family which
looks after the country whichever party
is in power a sense of continuity okay
and um we will talk to you again in in
terms of continuity we will be talking
to again a little later on but at the
moment Anthony and Julie thanks very
much indeed
so let's take a look at how the
newspapers are reporting the coronation
this morning and crowning glory is the
headline and the sun on Sunday the paper
writing that a glorious moment of
History was captured
the Sunday Mirror Has a picture of the
king carrying the orb and the scepter
whilst the start leads with the same
picture from the ceremony
the Sunday Express pictures the king
waving with the headline happy and
glorious
the mail on Sunday has a photograph of
the king and queen together on the
Buckingham Palace balcony with the
caption the look that says darling it
was a Triumph
and the same image makes the front of
the Sunday Times their headline at last
their crowning Glory
the Sunday Telegraph also features a
picture of the royal couple both wearing
crowns from the ceremony
the Sunday people devotes its whole
front cover to a picture of King Charles
waving
and the Observer pictures the King on
the front but it leads with analysis of
Thursday's local election results
Now The Prince and Princess of Wales
have released a video of their
coronation day with the caption what a
day
[Music]
well it includes some behind the scenes
footage which was published on their
Instagram account and they added a
message which said thank you to everyone
who made it happen
and if one photo perhaps may become
symbolic of yesterday's historic events
it might be this one
the king and queen on the balcony of
Buckingham Palace as an enormous crowd
looks back at them wearing their crowns
King Charles III and queen Camilla went
out for a final Encore together
and the Red Arrows have tweeted cockpit
videos showing what it's like to be
involved in an RAF fly past nine red
arrows took part in What was a scale
backfly pass because of the weather more
than 60 aircraft were meant to be
involved but in the end they were just
25.
well tonight the king and queen will
join 20 000 members of the public at a
coronation concert at Windsor Castle
amongst the Stars will be performing Are
Lionel Richie and Katy Perry who at the
coronation service
well the coronation celebrations do
continue today with Street parties and
community events taking place across the
country so let's find out a little bit
more about them our correspondent Alice
Porter is in the mail for us this
morning and Alice tell us a little bit
more about what's being planned for
today then
well I think we can expect lots of
bunting jelly and cream teas as people
from around the UK will very much all
come together we're expecting more than
67 000 people lunches are being held
across the bank holiday weekend
including what's being called a big
knees up at London's Regents Park
members of the royal family are also
getting involved Edward and Sophie will
attend a street party at cranley in
Surrey or Princess Anne will drop in on
a party in Swindon and it's understood
that the Prime Minister will also be
hosting a big lunch at Downing Street
with Ukrainian refugees and volunteers
who will be there as well and very much
the idea of this is to have communities
come together there'll be many Charities
who will use these lunches as a way of
raising important money and I think very
much the atmosphere that the royal
family be wanting to emanate is what we
saw last year at the Queen's Platinum
Jubilee celebrations where we saw Street
parties across the countries with people
very much coming together of course this
will be the first time that this sort of
Street parties of people coming across
together in the communities sharing sort
of sandwiches and you know a few bits of
bubbly as well this will be the first
time this has happened really since the
queen passed away last year so we'll be
very much a moment for the king and the
country to come together to celebrate
the bank holiday weekend
lovely Alice I will be checking in on
you throughout the day but for a moment
thanks very much indeed
so there'll still be plenty of Bunting
and beer today as people across the
country get together well let's talk a
little bit more about what's planned
Lindsey brummett is the program director
at Eden Project communities that's the
charity behind the big lunch idea so
just the person to talk to Lindsay nice
to see you this morning good morning um
so the big lunch is going to be a focus
of many communities up and down the
country but it was originated by the at
the Eden Project wasn't it yeah tell us
a little bit about its history how it
came to life yeah so way back in 2009
it's an idea from Eden that it's just
about getting people together so what
could happen if you get people together
right across the country on one weekend
of the Year having food sharing
friendship and let's see what happens
and actually from the very first year
it's grown and grown and grown and so
many great things flow from it so Eden
is kind of a movement of people want to
make positive change and the big lunch
is an extension of that what we see is
communities getting together joining in
having fun getting to know one another
and then they go on to do so many more
things like fundraising
babysitting circles borrowing drills
instead of buying them all the good
things that can can help communities
knit together well yes and as you say
all about bringing communities together
but the royal family have been involved
in it as well haven't they I think the
queen consort has been to a few events
she has been to many events and um she
is our Patron so we're very pleased
we've been working with her since 2013
when we did uh the first uh big Jubilee
lunch so yeah she's been involved for
many years and is really passionate
about seeing people come together and
enjoy those celebrations and I I
understand though that the king and
queen won't be involved in any of the
big lunch events today is that
disappointing or completely
understandable given I think if I'd
solve the day they did yesterday yeah I
think I'd be relaxing with a cup of tea
and watching the nation take part so I
think that's the really lovely thing
it's happening everywhere it's right
from the Shetland Isles down to the
silly Isles we've got big lunches
happening in so many communities so I
think they'll just enjoy sitting back
and watching what's going on well yes
what do you make of the takeout because
I think people do register don't they
and let you know that it's going on so
what kind of uh scale are they on and do
they do they reach far and wide are
there certain areas that are more
interesting no they reach far and wide I
mean uh in a normal year so when we
haven't got some sort of Royal uh
occasion to to be part of uh we'd see
about six seven eight thousand pack
requests this year we've got 67 000
packed requests so that's a lot of
events right across the country we've
also had some from overseas so we've got
people taking part in about 36 different
countries I think so um we're very
excited to see um how that all unfolds
today and when people do apply to do it
what do you think they want do you think
it's about an excuse to get together
with their neighbors or do you think it
really is about celebrating the royal
family how much connections do you think
it really has got to the coronation
um I think there's a real mix so I think
some people do it every year and have
been coming together just because they
want to get their note to know their
neighbors better or want to raise money
for something that matters to them
and other people are going actually this
is a chance for a right Royal knees up
so we've got everything in the mix we've
got people doing dog shows we've got
people doing fancy dress parades and I
think that's the wonderful thing about
it and the national lottery fund it and
I think that's because it is an excuse
to invite the nation to come together
for a party but the good things flow
from that party and what about what's on
the menu will the coronation quiche pop
up at all do you think this is the
recipe selected by the royal family
wasn't it um and it's a spinach and
Butterbean it's broad Bean spinach and
tarragon yes so there have been lots of
comments about the ingredients very
seasonal we have a giant one down at the
Eden Project today so 32 inch giant
coronation quiche going there so there
will definitely be some quiche available
I think there's going to be more
coronation chicken there be honest
um I oh I haven't tried the keys
actually but I love coronation chicken
so I imagine that will also be featuring
heavily I just think it will be anyway
Lindsay from it really interesting to
talk to you thanks very much indeed for
coming along
well the UK is waking up with a newly
crowned king and queen thousands of
Street parties are expected to take
place across the country today which for
some people will evoke happy childhood
memories of the last coronation in 1953.
shiggy mararike reports now from settle
in Yorkshire
it was all all in the Market Square
hundreds of people strugged down that
side more or less where the middle of
the road is going up here between the
yellow lines so quite an event they live
in 1953. I think it brought all your
community together you never were really
split up what denomination you were
what age you were you were all brought
together and you all celebrated it from
youngsters where I took to grandparents
age so it was well well attended on the
day Millions will Mark the crowning of a
new monarch in their local communities
John can remember the same moment 70
years ago he was part of a parade in his
home of settle North Yorkshire winning
first prize for his costume
out of any sort of material that she had
available and was suitable after another
milestone in British history he thinks
protecting and preserving are links to
the Past are important it's bringing all
your memories back and you can share
that day with whoever you're talking to
when our family come open our
grandchildren and they say what did you
do when you did short or Granddad and I
said well just to me we'll get to four
to go pound and I'll show you so I
American personal information on to
another two generations down there are
not a lot of people living locally who
actually will remember these events so
it's nice to have it documented
in these communities they've long
celebrated jubilees and coronations for
a king well known as a champion of the
countryside they want those Traditions
to continue
the best one from 1935 I think showing
the the banner there God bless our King
first made for George V for the last 70
years these banners were used for the
queen in nearby land cliff now the
original wording is back on display I
was blown away by them because I just
think they're they're so wonderful
really that we've still got them after
all this time uh yeah there's a sense of
time very much in those photos and and
now I suspect yes we will celebrate but
it won't it's it's not going to be on
the same scale I'm afraid we're not not
doing so much
however people choose to celebrate
stories from this weekend will be told
for generations to come shinki marike
Sky News North Yorkshire
well Charles was always destined to be
king but how did that influence his
childhood well Johnny Stoneboro attended
goldenstone school with King Charles and
he's here with me now so very good
morning to youth thanks so much for
coming along so you were at gordonston
in Northern Scotland with King Charles
when he was a boy so yeah we did four
years together so what was he like three
years ago it's a long time isn't it yeah
what was he like well when I first met
him he was shy introverted very
withdrawn and it didn't get any much
better because he got so badly bullied
at the beginning I think the first two
years were hell for him actually well
yeah tell us a little bit about that he
really well I mean you know there wasn't
exactly a great deal of pastoral care
they didn't know about those sort of
things and it was very monastic and you
were just told to get on with it not
complain and the whole stiff upper lip
business you know make a man of you but
actually if you're being bullied which
is what was happening to him
um it's very difficult to cope with and
he didn't really have have any friends
if you were if you tried to be friends
with him and many people did because
he's he's a very nice chap actually once
you get to know
um you know they got bullied for trying
to be friends with with with our future
king or the king and uh so it was a
ridiculous situation was that why he was
bullied because he was the Future King I
don't know I think there was just a sort
of institutionalized bullying anyway
just sort of the the senior boys would
would have a crack at the at the Juniors
and they'd come rampaging like a sort of
uh uh I don't know like sort of Mongol
hordes I don't know through the
dormitories tip everybody out of bed
shove you into a
um a laundry basket leave you under the
cold shower uh I mean you know it was a
wild place he did have one friend though
didn't he had his bodyguard oh Sergeant
Green we liked Sergeant Green yes he was
a London copper and he was his bodyguard
but he got fired unfortunately it was an
absolute tragedy the uh that was the
famous Cherry Brandy incident and and as
a result his detective was fired but of
course he was his his one Confidant
remind us what the Cherry brand oh yeah
of God they went uh they they were
sailing the school did a lot of sailing
and they went out storn away uh in The
Western Isles they went to the crown
Hotel uh in stornaway uh they could have
gone to the cinema but they didn't they
were about 14 or 15. I wasn't Along on
that particular cell and uh they they
decided they everyone was asked what
they wanted to drink you know Young
Prince Charles hadn't got a clue what he
wanted to drink so he's 14 yeah he's 14.
so he said I'll have a Cherry Brandy I
wish to this day he probably wishes he'd
asked for a pound of lager or at least a
shandy and uh
it was it just went viral it went
completely totally viral somebody
shocked him to the to the tabloids it
was all over the papers but the the
collateral damage was Sergeant Green
lost his job and the prince lost his
only friend he lost his confidence yeah
one sort of happier image that you have
is you actually dance with him yeah
there were there were no women at gaunts
this sort of monastic environment but
they used to try and sort of uh trade
you a little bit to you know cope with
the real world and so we had dancing
classes very specifically Highland
Dallas classes so we were just be paired
off together uh I'd do the whole kind of
you know that business yeah and your
wife likes to tell this yeah my wife my
wife is abused but you know that she
married the man who danced with the
Prince of Wales yeah absolutely I love
that Twist on it yeah so what you know
about him as a child to what extent do
you think his experiences at school have
informed how he is today well I I tell
you you know there's no way that you go
through that without without it damaging
you there's the you know being badly
bullied is a very very isolating and
painful experience as many people would
tell you one of the positive things I I
think is that maybe there are children
out there now who are being bullied and
to know that the king of Britain you
know also was quite bad bullied maybe
that gives them a little bit of strength
you can get through it but at the time
you cut you know it's awful and do you
think that affects how he deals with
other people do you think he has more
empathy yes as a result absolutely I'm
sure that his interest in his in in
people uh and his his natural concern
about about the natural world about
about the environment about people and
people's lives you know I think if he'd
gone to a different school he maybe
would have been more more distant more
removed from The Real World Gordon said
at least gave him that I and and what
about his dealing with challenges that
sense of never explain never complained
yeah that came from those early days
well we were all brought up very much on
the never complaint never explained sort
of rule of life
um the stiff upper lip it was very much
the that was what we were told just get
on with it and of course his father
would have understood that you know that
I'm sure that uh I I wasn't party to any
conversations but I'm sure that his
father would have just said just you
know be a man get on with it and finally
your thoughts on seeing him crowned
yesterday oh I loved it absolutely loved
it I sat there because I of course
remember the previous one and we sat in
front of a little tiny television a
little black and white one had all the
neighbors around and yesterday was no
different we had all the neighbors
around it Telly's a bit bigger and it's
color of course but it was just the same
yeah oh well Johnny Steinberg very
interesting to get your your analysis of
of yesterday but also to tell us a
little bit about uh King Charles the boy
very interesting thanks so much for your
time thank you time now to delve into
the Sunday paper see how they're
covering the coronation this morning
here with me to look at them are Ian
Lloyd a royal biographer and author of
The Throne one thousand years of British
coronations and journalist afia Hagan so
welcome back to both of you we dealt
with all the front pages dominated as
you would imagine by yesterday's big
event of course but let's take a look
further in shall we in you've picked up
a double page spread to kick us off and
this is this extraordinary photograph I
certainly have never seen a photo from a
previous coronation it's probably not
very many that were photographed but
um but I haven't seen quite anything
quite like this what do you make of it
well it's it's fascinating because it
shows the king and queen and the people
together so it's taken by Chris Jackson
from inside the palace as you said the
one unknown factor about the coronation
well any big thing a jubilee or a royal
funeral or wedding
is the people because you don't know
who's going to turn up I mean I I
expected fewer and I also expected that
there may be demonstrators down here
with you know that we don't want to this
king or whatever it is not talking
um but it was I was with the crowd down
there I moved down the mall and it was
universally euphoric and in the rain
Yeah well yeah the only chant I heard
was put your brolies down put your
brollies down because the people at the
front had their umbrellas so uh once
that was sorted out then it was fine and
there was lots of cheering spontaneous
three cheers and you know one one
unusual thing I've covered about
um 20 of these big occasions is I've
never seen the Monarch go in and then
come out and that's what Charles did
they all went in they came out on mass
and then he came out finally with just
Camilla a little bit of an encore yeah
sort of an encore and I think that was
because he was incredibly moved by it I
mean I was near enough with a big lens
to see that he was very affected by it
and I think and also really interesting
just to see that picture and and the
back of both of them a reminder that the
queen was crowned as well as the king
yesterday and that's obviously something
we certainly didn't see in 1953 in the
same way no absolutely I mean Prince
Philip had really a walk on part there
was no constitutional role for him as a
consult but uh the last time was 1937 so
there's hardly anybody that can remember
that and that was the uh his
grandparents the King George and Queen
Elizabeth
um and there's a sort of similarity I
mean the the you know if you look at
that the The Capes and the crowns
obviously I mean they're very much a
team and some of the photographs have
shown them talking to each other and
you've got that feeling that uh yeah
from the day together absolutely and
take us into the Sunday Express now
because while this was a a formal event
the service full of tradition there was
also the family element as well and of
course Prince Harry he was was one of
those tricky issues that the the family
had to navigate so how does the express
deal with this is something Express
absolutely so Harry did a 10 there was
rumors flying around on Friday that he
may not be there but of course he was
there um he entered Westminster Abbey
with Beatrice and new zini his cousins
um Zara Mike Phillips as well and Mike
Tindall and Zara Phillips excuse me
um and he walked down the aisle into the
church into Westminster Abbey with them
were seated in the third row and he
looked quite happy quite relaxed he was
smiling to people as he went past
greeting people the lip readers have
been out in for us already God bless
them apparently at one point he said
about a quarter to four o'clock to
someone and they've interpreted that as
perhaps that was his flight because
after the servers finished at West man
Winston Arabi he was straight into a car
and straight to Heathrow Airport uh into
the Windsor suite and off back to LA for
his son's birthday and you know he did
join in was saying and God Save the King
and Long Live King Charles and yeah and
he just seemed to have you know just
sort of sat there was relaxed look quite
happy they got it about right he was
there and and reasonably supportive but
not playing a prominent role did that
feel about right yeah absolutely because
I mean he's not a working Royal
um so we couldn't we would not expect to
see him on the balcony which I think was
absolutely right
um and you know he came he saw and he
went back home again so I think you know
there's so much written about him which
I find quite funny but there wasn't
really much to say and I think people
are trying to trying to milk those
headlines I mean a lot of people talking
about Princess Anne's hats and how
Princess Anne said to do a few of the
view of him yes she was wearing the
blues and Royals uniform and she had
that red plume on her hat and a lot of
people were like oh I wish he plays
there deliberately no yeah
happy to hide behind it who knows um but
Ian but you wanted to talk particularly
about the Royal Coach which was
spectacular it was yes and I mean that's
the first time that's been used for a
coronation obviously since 1953 they
obviously don't like it that much the
lake Queen called it horrible and Queen
Victoria said it was um distressing
oscillations because the trouble is what
happens is it's it's not sprung it's
this great four-ton coach that's um
gilded wood uh that's based that sits on
these enormous leather straps so what
happens is you've got eight horses
pulling you forward so you've got that
feeling of being pulled forward also you
swing slightly to the side
so um the Sailor King William IV said it
was like being at Sea and um you know
you can imagine it's and it's so heavy
that it can only go to walking pace
which was actually quite good because
that gave you slightly more time to uh
to see what was happening and there's
other shots of the royal couple leaving
the Abbey they didn't go to The Abbey no
they went in the um in the the more
modern Diamond Jubilee coach
um I think the um the slight pain with
the goal State coach built in 1762 is
that
um you can't see very well through the
windows I mean it wasn't designed to be
seen in that way and if you look at the
the footage you're showing I mean you
can just see Charles at that angle boo
yes he passes that uh bits of the
culture in the way yeah it's very Disney
princess isn't it
um take us on um now Affair to um the
sun on Sunday this is um again another
spread but looking at the Fashions and
there was a lot of focus on on the
younger Royals wasn't there yeah so the
younger Royals did very well yesterday
and but I thought what I thought was
super cute is yeah the Princess of Wales
and Princess Charlotte were actually
matching in this Alexander McQueen dress
so princess Charlotte was wearing sort
of a pair down version of Kate's
Alexander McQueen ivory silk Cape Brown
this was designed by Sarah Barton it was
embroidered with rose Shamrock daffodil
and thistle motifs to signify the
foreign Nations and they had a silver
headpiece not a tiara Silver Head pieces
uh created by Milano Jessica in
conjunction with Alexander McQueen as
well and Kate was also wearing Pearl and
diamond earrings that belonged to their
Anna Princess of Wales and I thought
they looked really really beautiful
actually the whole family and and Kate
and Charlotte matching is really really
sweet I think it's great that they had
the Matisse of all the four nations on
there as well but I think they're also
looking forward to a time where perhaps
these pieces might go into a museum and
they really wanted to give us sort of a
vision or a piece of what it looked like
at the beginning of the Caroline age
yeah and so much symbolism and so much
detail from every last bit of embroidery
yeah um it is quite extraordinary and it
was quite funny watching Princess Anne
because she had two roles she was gold
sticking waiting so she had this uniform
but when she got there she had to be a
member of the royal family and put on
these robes as well so we didn't see
that happening but it must have happened
very quickly as she got off the horse it
was brilliantly stage management the
whole thing wasn't they all look very
smooth and and Ian you've picked out a
piece also in in the sun on Sunday
um of this this rather poignant moment I
mean there was so much formality and yet
there was this this family moment if you
like when Prince William kissed his
father yeah absolutely I mean that he
had the role of also putting his
father's super Tunica on this
um golden
um coat that he put on before that and
you could see Charles saying thank you
and it was almost like role reversal
because when you're little your mum does
that to you but he was doing it back to
him and um it was a very touching
emotional moment I think and it I think
shows the the closeness of the father
and son and I my prediction is that he's
going to be a kind of a joint monarchy
that William will be involved in
everything and you actually saw it with
the procession because at the Queen's
the lake Queens coronation and previous
ones the king and queen come in on their
own but they actually came in
with um the king queen came in with the
Wales just didn't they in the procession
so it's very much part of you know
unified I think there's going to be a
teamwork all round I guess well I'm in
an affair it's really lovely to have
your company this morning the morning
after the night before yeah you're at
Buckingham Palace reflecting on the day
yesterday thanks so much